We regret to inform you that Skyscraper has
collapsed.
Pitched as "Die Hard meets The Towering Inferno,"
the Dwayne Johnson-led action movie premiered
to a significantly lower-than-expected financial
reception, coming out of its first weekend
in third place at the box office.
As a result, the would-be franchise starter
will be lucky to make its money back, much
less spark a new series.
More likely than not, you can forget about
a sequel already.
So why is this disaster movie proving to be
such a… disastrous movie?
Could the Rock's star be fading?
Is the movie actually that bad?
Let's tally up the numbers and figure out
the real reasons Skyscraper couldn't stand
tall at the box office.
What's the damage?
According to a breakdown by The Hollywood
Reporter, Skyscraper only managed a domestic
total of $25.5 million in its opening weekend.
The unexpectedly small take falls below Universal's
projected opening of $30 million or more.
Against a budget of more than $125 million
and a marketing budget of at least half that,
those numbers are a pretty poor showing, one
which Box Office Mojo predicts will translate
into a $65 to $75 million domestic total.
Since these projected earnings wouldn't even
cover half of Skyscraper's total cost, that
leaves a huge deficit to bridge in the international
market, just for the sake of breaking even.
But with only $40.4 million coming in from
the movie's global audience on opening weekend,
the chances of even that happening are looking
vanishingly small.
I think I've seen this
If Skyscraper feels too familiar to be all
that interesting, that's actually partially
by design.
Prior to the movie's release, Johnson described
the movie on his social media as "a film that
paid homage and respect to the classic action
movies that inspired me and entire generations
- Die Hard to Towering Inferno to The Fugitive."
The thing about those classic action movies
is not just that we've seen them before, but
that we've also already seen them all get
ripped off.
We've seen Cliffhanger, we've seen Speed,
we've seen Daylight - and they all feel a
lot like Skyscraper.
So as much as Johnson and the movie's producers
would like to praise Skyscraper as a modern
classic, it's not a quality that feels all
that earned.
It doesn't help that Skyscraper comes off
as feeling similar to some of Dwayne Johnson's
other recent movies, from San Andreas to Rampage
to even The Fate of the Furious.
But that's not this movie's problem - that
speaks to issues with the movie's marquee
star.
Over-exposed
Over a 14-month span starting in April 2017,
Dwayne Johnson has been a lead star in five
different movies, including Baywatch, Jumanji,
and now Skyscraper.
The avalanche of content shows no signs of
stopping, but it might already be bringing
in diminishing returns.
In short, Johnson has opened himself up to
the possibility of serious overexposure.
With no less than ten movies potentially coming
down the pipeline for the actor, you'd have
to be crazy not to think that we're at risk
of some serious Rock fatigue.
If it can happen to Star Wars, it can happen
to the People's Champion.
Could Skyscraper's failure inspire Johnson
to tone down the full-court press?
Maybe.
After all, how is the country ever going to
elect him president if everyone's burned out
on his movies?
The competition
Whatever its own faults may be, Skyscraper
was also outmatched at the box office by more
critically acclaimed competition.
On one side, there's Hotel Transylvania 3:
Summer Vacation, another entry in the Adam
Sandler-starring animated series about Dracula
and friends.
That family-friendly sequel won the weekend
with $45 million, easily trouncing Skyscraper's
debut showing.
In second place, there's Ant-Man and the Wasp,
with nearly $29 million.
According to both Rotten Tomatoes scores and
Cinemascores, people walked out of these two
movies feeling satisfied, and ready to spread
some positive word of mouth.
To its detriment at the box office, Skyscraper
is proving more divisive, and without good
word of mouth behind it, things are only going
to get worse from here.
Catch it later
So does Skyscraper really deserve this belly-flop
of a reception?
Well, yes and no.
Put simply, Skyscraper is not the kind of
appointment viewing that makes you want to
schlep out to the cinema, regardless of how
bombastic its special effects might be.
Instead, it's the kind of thing you see accidentally,
killing time with an in-flight movie while
you're on a plane.
Multiple reviews emphasized the movie's nature
as something slight and inessential - enjoyable
enough as a nice diversion, but not good for
much else.
In a crowded movie landscape, "good enough"
often doesn't cut it - not when other movies
are competing for the same audience.
In these days of razor-thin profit margins,
sometimes that's all you need to make a box-office
bomb.